est ce que on doit absolument avoir une
enquête indépendante externe pour savoir
comment lé enquête policière a été menée
walid ben ça va être intéressant j'ai
hâte de voir comment les institutions
vont réagir à la situation parce qu'à
première vue la situation elle est
manifestement problématique
il y avait plusieurs signale ici un
individu sans histoire au camp passé
criminel ou via laquelle que ce soit une
étudiant quelqu'un de normal qui se
serait arrangé un point tel pour un
ticket est un constat d'infraction qui
leur est battu avec une barre de fer
prix larmes
siri sur un point ici déjà première vue
la théorie était était elle frappe
et comment ne procéder à son
identification il y avait un vidéo qui
démontrait qu'il y avait une autre
personne quand comment on a manipulé
cet enregistrement eu égard aux critères
applicables avant de poursuivre
quelqu'un on doit être sûr au niveau de
la poursuite là qu'on a une bonne
identification et avoir une conviction
morale qu'on va obtenir une condamnation
être qu'on apprend ici on voit que
c'était très approximatif com com com
identification alors il ya plusieurs
questions qui sont pour le moment sans
réponse
bon martin je viens vous après mais où
elle est juste comment se fait-il alors
selon vous qu'est ce qui a pu arriver
pour que le dpcp disent vous avez très
bien on a ce qu'il faut
on y va je sais pas et justement un
procureur aux planètes
la police a bien peu à voir sa vision
des choses mais procureur qui analyse le
dossier avant d'autoriser une plainte il
doit avoir cette conviction morale et ça
ça va dépendre de la qualité de la
preuve
alors pourquoi le dpcp a décidé
d'accuser ici c'est les seuls qui
peuvent répondre non je me suis avancé
de recul un petit peu c'est sûr que les
crimes étaient très graves
un policier qui le sujet d'une tentative
de meurtre c'est extrêmement grave
mais ce qu'on avait le bon suspect ici
pourquoi l'accusé aussi rapidement
encore manifestement ce n'est pas le bon
suspect martin biron lit suite selon
vous à tous à ce que québec n'a pas le
choix maintenant que de d'organiser une
forme d' enquête d'examen de ce qui
s'est passé
oui je pense que c'est une enquête juste
sous quelle forme est inévitable et
demandez je dirais pas à peu près tous
les élus on a entendu la ministre de la
sécurité publique à québec la mairesse
valérie plante là on a parlé hier
pendant son point de presse qu'elle
souhaitait une enquête et le premier
ministre justin trudeau en a rajouté lui
aussi en demandant une enquête
indépendante alors ça devient inévitable
quand il ya une faute d'unanimité là
dessus c'est parier qu'on arrête
monsieur camara rapidement c'est une
chose mais qu'on ait lucine pas l'erreur
avant six jours c'est quand même très
long hier c'est un peu fou là la journée
la façon dont ça s'est passé on était
très impétueux du côté des autorités
tant du côté politique que du côté du
chef caron il a eu l'amabilité de régler
la situation très rapidement là il ya eu
des informations dans de 24 heures et il
est sorti pour les rendre publiques et
remettre les rétablir les faits
maintenant il faut savoir ce qui s'est
passé à l'air au service de police de
montréal pour avoir comment ils ont
déclenché cette enquête là est ce qu'ils
ont et et émotivement pris dans ce qui
arrivait à l'un des leurs
faudra le savoir et il ya qu'est ce qui
se passe au dpcp quelles sortes de
questions on a posé pour aller de
l'avant avec ces accusations la m jazy
là je me faire l'avocat du diable caunes
avocat ce qu'un drôle mais monsieur
caron a dit hier on attendait des
résultats de l'échantillon de l'adn et
tout ça de sambre est ce que il se peut
que la scène est était à ce point et
bleuse que ça tenait quand même la route
jusqu'à un certain point que ça soit
mamadi et que seul le résultat qu'il a
reçu ce matin pouvait le disculper
est-ce que ce que ça peut tenir la route
c'est présomptueux je le reconnais dans
l'abstrait ici
réponse à cette question se retrouve
dans les images que l'on voit dans la
vidéo
et c'est à peu près tous conseillers on
ne sait pas exactement comment la scène
s'est déroulée sur une scène très
violente mais qui était présent sur les
lieux c'était une opération pour arrêter
des conducteurs pour des violations au
code de la route est ce que c'était
combien de voitures y avait-il y
avait-il d'autres témoins monsieur lui
même appelé le 9-1-1 pour pour témoigner
de la situation ne l'a pas prise au
sérieux
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement
lors de l'événement c'est ce qu'on a
besoin de savoir pour tirer des
conclusions grave là mais à première vue
pour les raisons que j'ai expliqué plus
tôt sa frappe la cip
y a pas le profil de l'individu on le
savait déjà et quand est ce qu'on a mis
la main sur l'encadrement qu'elle est
quelles sont les images
alors on a beau attendent une preuve
externe qui vient confirmer ou infirmer
une présence d' adn ou de l'ap la poudre
à canon et c'est une image là qui montre
que s'est passé il ya quoi dans l'image
ouais on l'a pas vu l'image en passe
alors on on vous parle de ses vidéos du
mtq là un peu plus loin mais apparemment
que c'est quand même un peu flou mais
martin bévues et villans en même temps
politiquement
hier la mairie cette avancée très très
vite son chef de police l'a contredit
deux heures après quelle histoire quand
même il ya plusieurs histoires dans
l'histoire
premièrement la mer et ce plan doit
respirer beaucoup mieux ce soir avec la
tournure des événements parce que hier
soir on se disait la vérité va trancher
mais c'était clair qu'il y avait d'un
côté la mairesse plantes et de l'autre
son chef de police
de son corps de police de montréal il ya
un fossé entre les deux alors est ce que
ce sera réconciliables nous sommes en
année électorale et ça compte on peut
pas écarter ce facteur là madame plantes
devra faire sa campagne après l'élection
si elle est réélue le chef car on aura
certainement des bonnes discussions avec
elles pour la suite des choses
c'est certain que ce qui est arrivé
c'était pas très élégant surtout pour
elle ou et puis le chef caron comme il
sait autant madame la mairesse s'est
allongé le coup hier en disant c'est sûr
qui est innocent alors que son chef de
police était pas rendu là lui il a
décidé de prendre une posture pour
défendre les policiers hier en disant
écoutez ce pas finie laissez nous
travailler ça va laisser des traces sur
la relation est ce qu'il peut rester
très longtemps vers un interminable m
jazy est-ce qu'il poursuit pour vous ce
que c'est une évidence au civil parce
que mamady poursuit c'est possible c'est
très possible nouveau public on a trop
peu d'informations pour évaluer la
situation mais à première vue il ya une
situation problématique ici va falloir
déterminer s'il ya eu on a agi de
mauvaise foi ou d'une façon vraiment
très négligente de négligence grossière
et encore une fois les critères
applicables sont bien connus depuis
longtemps pour une conviction morale
avant d'accuser il faut s'assurer qu'on
a une bonne identification
ce qu'on a agi trouvent etc de façon
négligente démesurément négligente
on verra si une enquête qui va décider
la situation très bien est ce que le où
l'équipe de procureurs avaient la
conviction morale qui pouvait pendant
six jours ils l'ont eu en tout cas ce
qu'il avait raison de l'avoir c'est tout
ça martine qu'une enquête devra nous
donner comme réponses oui et ça devrait
s'attacher commence à s'attacher au
cours de la semaine prochaine parce que
est ce que le véhicule le meilleur c'est
le bureau des enquêtes indépendantes ce
qu'on appelle le b2i qui généralement
enquête sur les pratiques policières
l'homme étant va vouloir aussi regarder
le rôle du
dpcp de la couronne dans ce dossier là
alors il faudra voir comment on va
organiser cette enquête là peut-être
qu'on va nommer quelqu'un d'extérieur et
indépendant mais pas nécessairement le
pays pour faire cette enquête
ouais je pense j'ai raison c'est plus
parce que ça s'en va merci à beaucoup
avouent de vraiment très apprécié toute
une soirée merci beaucoup au revoir